I got a quarterback option with elite  sauce leet sauce that that's me I'm Ally  here you go  that was really fast you must be  exhausted yeah I'm saving up to go back  to college hey Joe  come sit with us we were just discussing  6-yard check downs listen guys no  offense but I'm a little bit more than a  game manager I'm gonna go sit over there  hi I'd like to apply for an elite QB  Club card okay great just a couple  questions to see if you qualify so have  you started in any Super Bowl yes and  did you win yep oh and I was also an MVP  so and was that league or Super Bowl  okay  I was also 2008 Rookie of the Year  that's great that's awesome all right so  have you ever thrown for more than four  thousand yards in a season I have and  how many times once one oh wow hey the  rest of your staff just popped a break  here technology right mmm  2012 season fantasy ownership 14% bikes  hey you know what let's just hit submit  oh sorry Natalie